[Music]
my name is Igor I'm an engineer in the
Android team hey my name is Sergey and I
work in the same team hi I'm Sean I'm
from Android dev rel okay today we are
going to talk about qualities on
androids but before we talk about that
let's try to figure out like why do you
even need some qualities and to
understand that let's get how you write
UI code on Android so this is the dream
code we want to write you like color
function makes a network request
whatever you get the user set it on the
text view this is what you want to write
but if you write that you get an
exception because you cannot make a
network request on the main thread easy
we just put an insider threat and run
the code now you're going to complain is
the text view which is like you cannot
touch the UI thread from a background
thread and okay go write this kind of
code where you make it a synchronous you
provide a callback it runs on the
background thread and cause your
callback on the UI thread and this code
works fine except if you're writing code
like this you're gonna receive out of
out of memory exceptions because you're
going to be leaking those callbacks left
and right there's a solution to this as
well where we can like have an
understanding of a subscription that
keeps his chain and whenever you're a
stop we can just cancel the subscription
that one works but then you end up
something like this and I'm not making
this up by the way three years ago when
we started architecture components I was
looking at the Google app code and I
found one application that had 26 lines
of amount math unregister so if it
happens at Google it happens everywhere
like we'd always write the base code but
there's a solution to this as well which
if you are using something like Eric's
Java and so this function returns an
observable you can just use the auto
dispose library associated subscription
with your real life cycle and safely
subscribe
and this works perfectly similarly you
could be using live data which enforces
you to have a life cycle to observe and
this also works so this whole problem
right why are we even talking here about
this if there's already good solutions
every year we run these developer
benchmark service we ask the voters how
are they doing but are there problems
and the service we run last year one of
the top cop plays was threading and
concurrency developer says this is hard
on Android and one of the top Lucas was
this week what we call live data plus
once the people want us to extend live
data make it more like Eric's Chara and
you're like why why do you want this we
have good solutions just use one of them
so we didn't bother we do best when we
don't know we did a UX research this is
a user experience research on
concurrency so we did in-depth
interviews with nine developers what
they do is they do the regular work for
a couple of weeks in their own company
and every time they see a problem about
concurrency like this observable T they
just write it down this was the problem
this is I sold it and this is how I feel
about it and in this study we focused on
three main things focused on live data
which is our observable date older we
focused on Eric Shaw with the reactive
Sims library and qualities which
provides suspend of all computations and
in the result of that study this was the
conclusion for live data people say we
love it but we want a complete solution
in fact is funny live data doesn't even
support anything but a main thread but
we talked about it in a concurrent study
for our Xterra it is amazing people love
and hate it they love how powerful it is
but the common complaint we always heard
was well as always misused it feels like
an overkill and for qualities this was
like it really looks like the best
solution but I'm not sure it's very new
it's not major so this was the overall
conclusion we said we need a solution
that is simple
it shouldn't be hard to learn that
solution it should be compressive so you
should be able to scale to different use
cases and it should be robots that
should be built in testing stories so
made two decisions we said okay we are
going to have first-class quality
support in jetpack and we are going to
have more support for rxjava in our
documentation but today it is all about
Cortese
so shut why don't you tell us a little
bit more about what qualities are thanks
you so I want to just take five minutes
and talk a little bit about what problem
carotenes are great at solving so in a
sentence the main problem the correcting
solve is simplifying async programming
by replacing callbacks which is quite
abstract so let's look at some samples
and see what that looks like I'm gonna
make an imaginary Network request three
ways the first style is what's called a
blocking style this is where the result
is returned directly from the function
let's see how that executes and for fun
I'm gonna run that on the main thread
when called
a blocking network Hall will block the
thread that called it so the entire time
that Network request is running the main
thread will be blocked and that's the
thread that has to update the UI and
handle user touches so the user will see
your app is frozen or it might even
crash now I do want to pause and say
there's nothing wrong with a blocking
style of network api's but it's not what
we want to do on android so to fix that
as he'd already talked about we commonly
introduce callbacks so let's see how bad
executes we're still gonna call this
from the main thread but now when fetch
user is called the main thread is free
to perform other work it can handle on
draw or respond to user touches and the
networking library is responsible for
finding another thread to actually run
the request when the result is ready the
network library can then use with a
callback I gave it to callback into my
code and let me know that it's ready
let's rewrite that exact same code with
co-routines
it looks just like the blocking style
the result of fetch user is available
immediately and I don't have to
introduce a callback to tell Collin I
want to
keep this with co-routines it has a
suspend modifier on the function and
when we run it still on the main thread
the main thread is unblocked just like
with callbacks and this is a key concept
of carotenes the networking request
still runs on another thread when the
result is ready it resumes the curry
team where it left off this code is much
simpler than the callback style while
still ensuring that I can write my
Android app and make it never freeze for
the user this is the key mechanism here
of correcting suspend and resume when a
KO routine is suspended it's not running
it's paused and when it resumes it picks
up from where it left off you can think
of suspending ko routine as taking a
callback from the rest of the function
so you've put it together suspend and
resume replaced callbacks we can even
visualize that the callback version and
the co-routine version execute almost
exactly the same way let's switch back
and take a look at fetch user how can we
call a function that makes a network
request from the main thread to start
we'll need to make fetch user another
suspending function
this tells Kotlin that it works with
care routines and inside will call
another suspending function called
with context well pass it dispatchers
done I am zooming in on those
dispatchers calling gives us three
dispatchers default IO and main and
they're used for different things
default should be used for CPU intensive
work things like transforming a list of
a hundred elements calling des futile or
pre computing text anything that takes
too long to run on the main thread
should run on the default dispatcher IO
is a dispatcher that's optimized for
blocking Network in disk IO you should
use it anytime you need to write code
that blocks an API like writing a file
or reading from a socket and main this
is the main thread on Android and
surprisingly it's our recommendation as
the right place to start co-routines in
response to UI events
since you're usually starting para teens
from the main thread staying there will
avoid extra work for simple operations
then when you need to transform a list
or write a file co-routines let you
switch to one of the other dispatchers
by using with context with context will
run the block that you pass it on the
dispatcher you tell it to so this block
here is gonna run on dispatchers dot IO
and I'm free to make blocking Network
calls this allows us to provide main
safe api's you can just make a function
that reads and writes from the network
like this and call it from the main
thread and this is a huge benefit on
Android now I don't have to worry about
what every single function what thread
it needs to run on instead I can just
call it and the function itself can
ensure that it's safe to be called from
the main thread to finish up introducing
pair routines let's take a look at how
Kotlin implements them every thread has
a call stack it's what you see in the
debugger or a stack trace it's how
collin keeps track of which function is
running and its local variables when you
call us to spend function Collin needs
to keep track of the fact it's running a
KO routine instead of a regular function
I'm gonna represent this as a suspend
marker
everything above the suspend marker will
be a couraging and everything below will
be a regular function then Kotlin calls
load user just like a normal function
it's gonna put a stack entry onto the
call stack and this is where any local
variables for load user would be stored
and then it just executes until it finds
another suspend function call now Kotlin
has to implement suspend how does it do
that
what's kind of simple once you figure it
out all Kotlin has to do is copy the
state of the function from the stack to
a place where it can save it for later
it'll put all suspended coverage scenes
out here and it's not structured like a
stack then Collin will actually call
fetch user creates another stack entry
and when it calls with context suspends
that as well so at this point
so at this point all of the curry teams
on the main thread are suspended and
this means the main thread is free to do
other work like handle on draw or
respond to user touches and this is
really really important when all of the
curry teens on a thread are suspended
the thread is free to do other work if
we fast forward a few seconds the
network result will be ready and Colin
will have to call resume in order to do
that it just takes the save state and
copies it backs over puts it on the
stack and resumes the function when it
resumes load user it'll just go ahead
and continue executing just like normal
load user head aired it would have
thrown an exception right there the
suspend and resume mechanism is the
magic behind co-routines and we wanted
to show it to you so you could
understand how they work as you start
using them in your code that wraps up
the core routines intro hurry teams on
android offer us the ability to simplify
our code by replacing callbacks and
allow us the ability to create main
safety to ensure we never block the main
thread now I'm going to hand it over to
Sergey who will talk a bit about
libraries you can use today with
heritance thanks John yeah those very
cool bits on ice but we really want to
benefit in our real application from it
and despite a very young age of curtains
there are libraries that already support
them in very stable orbit artifacts and
I want to start with work manager that
is Payoneer for us in Android X because
it's already supports car scenes in its
stable release and you can use this
curtain worker but let's make a step
back and try to figure out why we do
that we use it so this is a typical flow
of workers so if you are not familiar of
work manager you can think of worker
just something that does long pink round
job it may have some constraints but
it's very simple just some work and
typical use case for that you need to
synchronize some local data with your
web server and this flow would look like
you query your
new notes from your database then upload
it to the web server lastly you just
mark those notes is successfully singing
well you see no need for curtsies well
actually we didn't start to talk about
translation because translation may
happen tea variety reasons for example
constraints for this worker aren't met
anymore or user explicitly cancel this
job if you provided this UI so how you
would support cancellation well you can
try to do something like that you try to
put like every other line this if check
and it starts to look silly and even
more it doesn't actually work because
this call which is probably most
expensive call because it goes to the
network and do some work there it
doesn't have any consolation signal
propagation because well if it was
started it will run till its end no
matter what and this actually will
curtail worker will help us with that we
didn't talk about that yet but curtains
don't really don't only ruff callbacks
nicely it also provides nice consolation
property so every system function can be
cancelled it can react on this
cancellation and also it propagates to
all inner calls this cancellation signal
well you may say our code inside those
calls are still blocking we don't
benefit from that anyhow this is true
however if you use room as your database
solution you can mark your queries and
suspense functions and then room will
take care of consolation for you as well
as fretting as Sean mentioned that in
multiple times this thing will be main
safe room takes care of reading it will
run the query on a background thread
then well nice our database calls are
canceled now but as we discussed before
the main call is this one and actually
if you use retrofit you can make it
suspend as well because retrofit already
for
suspend modifier for its Network calls
and I want to highlight that a retrofit
isn't part of Android X it's a just job
that's done via a community Android
Android a cotton community embraces
college scenes and we like it at the end
of a day it's less work for us so nice
now this code supports constellation and
it looks as as easy as it looked before
so we got a constellation for free so
this was a quick look on the things that
were available today and it will present
you a lot of new price that we just made
so so far we talked about what you could
do with qualities and for the rest part
of this talk we are going to talk about
new stuff so first one is live data and
qualities now just to be very clear live
data is not designed for concurrency
it's an observable value holder and you
are expected to be able to access the
value from the main thread that's like
intentional but that doesn't mean it
should not be interoperable so this is
what we are going to provide you today
there will be easy way to use live data
with Cortese so the most common use case
is you have some value you want to
compute in a quarantine but smart to
serve the result is a live data so to
turn starting today with the lifecycles
2.2 of a one artifact you get this new
one new API called live data so it's a
builder function very similar to the
sickness wielders in Cortland inside
that you pass a quality block and he
said you could do whatever you want and
call this amid function to dispatch
values so if you look at this data with
load function it is HLS husband function
and because you are calling the image
with a user in this case we can infer
that type for you so you don't even need
to specify this so this very simple
light that the API bridges the gap
between your live data elements and your
qualities so you get that ap a little
bit more in detail so it receives three
parameters and the first one is a
contact so why do we need a context well
if this data is loaded user function is
not less than the sass file function
which is a regular function and you
write this code you are going to receive
an eye on main thread exception because
this vlog by default resume dispatchers
main but you can change that we can tell
it give it a context as dispatchers IO
and now this code will work perfectly I
want you to notice that I didn't change
any contents of the code because you can
omit from whatever dispatcher you want
you don't need to be on the main
dispatcher to change the values now the
second one is a really awkward parameter
called timeout and to understand why we
needed a timeout parameter let's look at
the a famous rotation problem on Android
so on the Left I have a view model that
serves a live data and on the right I
have an activity that's observing it so
when my activity goes to started state
the live data will become active which
means ok you're an observer visible to
the user you are better off creating
some values but during that time what if
our activity rotates and so it's going
to be stopped
my data will become inactive be
destroyed and a new activity will come
so right now there is no one observing
live data so there's no reason to
produce results except after the new one
goes started again it becomes active
again so the problem we are trying to
solve here is this gap where live data
quickly becomes inactive and active in a
very quick succession like usual less
than one second
so how do we fix that let's look at the
detail how we run that code block and to
understand it better
we're just going to write a timer
function it's basically creates a timer
for live data
it gets the current time returns a live
data builder and in an infinite loop it
just missed the time the last one second
a miss the time delays one second and
never ends and this code I'm showing is
hundred percent okay to write how does
it actually work when the live data
returned by this blog becomes active we
check okay did we run this block and if
we didn't run that block now we start
executing it while we're executing it if
that block becomes inactive like if the
live data becomes inactive
we check okay is this block still
running and if it is still running we
give it some time to finish but even
after the timeout if it is still running
and we are inactive that's basically
unnecessary computation there is no one
observing the live data but the block
keeps running so we just cancel the
continuation the recording so if the
like that' becomes active again we're
just going to restart it and we only do
it once so if it finished the completion
there is no reason to restart it now you
can also emit more than one value so
this was some structure around this
sample we had before where we have a
repository that has a get user function
a lot user function and the loss from
the database and a Miss Tattaglia now
most of the time this is not the code
you write you need to go to the web
service fetch an updated user update the
database and omit that value again so
you could call emit as many times as you
want as long as you're inside that
quarantine block but you might say well
most of the time the database doesn't
return you a user it returns your live
data for user because you want to be
notified about the changes
well all you can say is you could just
call a meat source if you ever used
mediator live data this is very similar
to at source where it says whatever
value comes from the slide data just
make it my value and you can run things
like transformations here oh also now we
don't need this extra emit because we
already observing the database so you
can get rid of it so this slide at the
API basically provides us a very nice
way to make likely to work with
qualities but how what we models thank
you so let's talk a little bit about how
to integrate into integrate carotenes
into your view models but first I'm
gonna talk a little bit about
Gleeks specifically co-routine leaks
these are very serious problem they're
kind of like a memory leak that we're
all familiar with but way worse a cover
team can resume itself and in addition
to using memory it can use CPU it could
write a file it could make a network
request that doesn't need to happen to
help us deal with care routine leaks
Kotlin introduced this idea of
co-routine scopes so what is this scope
well it's really just a way of keeping
track of your co-routines
all care routines must run in a scope
and a scope gets the ability to cancel
all of the carotenes inside of it in
addition they're also the place that
uncaught exceptions formica routine gets
shuffled off to now you put that all
together and you can use scopes to help
ensure that you never leaked occur
routine work manager that Sergei talked
about provides a scope so does the live
data builder that yet just talked about
view model scope is a scope it's an
extension property on view model from
the KTX library I'm gonna do another one
of those scary infinite loop things that
Yeats showed but this time in a
quarantine that I start myself interview
model it uses view model scope to launch
a quarantine in the scope and by default
this launches on main then it starts an
infinite loop that doesn't know how to
stop itself and every second it's gonna
go ahead and write a file now that's
pretty expensive it's cover teams don't
make writing files faster
cheaper and we definitely don't want to
leak this work human scope lets us write
code like this safely when the user
navigates away from the screen the scope
will be canceled which guarantees this
very expensive work one week so if you
model scope can help you avoid
co-routine leaks by guaranteeing all
your cover teens are canceled whenever a
user leaves the screen I'm gonna pass it
over to Sergei he's gonna talk about
some other scopes writing yeah thanks
Jon yep another thing that's very
naturally provides scope is lifecycle
because as you can say from his name
something that has a start and the end
and if you think you are not familiar
face lifecycle owner interface you're
actually are because it is your activity
it is your fragment and don't forget
that fragment conveniently has two
different life cycles and the second one
is associated with views inside of it
and fortunately for me I don't have to
talk about that but let's defined scope
more precise there so as you know your
fragments are get recreated over with do
you configuration changes so it's life
cycle can lifetime can be shorter it can
be longer and lexical scope just mirrors
that meaning that once your lifecycle
owner receives destroy event lifecycle
scope gets cancelled and all its energy
ups are canceled as well so as you can
see the recycle scope is very tightly
coupled with UI and it works best in
situation like that so previously you
would have you do something like this
when you decide to show some UI will
delay and well this looks pretty simple
so we can make it a bit harder and if we
have a two steps it becomes to look very
ugly because of this deep nesting and
actually if you take a closer look you
have some real issues here because this
main Handler and those functions that
touch you I don't really work nicely
together because main handler is kind of
a global scope it doesn't care about
your lifecycle at all and those
functions have reference to fragments
or activities so if your delay is long
enough you can easily leak a lot of them
and receive out of memory exception well
my second scope will cancel all those
callbacks we are so for us is a
kind of a callback because it's suspend
function it will cancel it automatically
once your life cycle is destroyed so
this code looks nicely because it's very
sequential and it is actually safer
however I have to say that life cycle
scope is a bit of a danger zone so let's
rewind a little bit I was the one who
show you that retrofit and room supports
suspend functions it shows you something
look that very family looks like that
when you say okay I will combine those
functions to network and database into
some repository pattern and I'll have
just one function which is suspend
function that orchestrate all of this
work so I just need the scope to call it
so why wouldn't I just call it in my
life cycle scope and it's actually not a
brightest idea
well why and don't get me wrong you can
Sean told you everything correctly it
won't lock main thread it wants the
curtains however do remember this
picture lexical scope get canceled on
every configuration change meaning that
your main that your network request gets
canceled every time so it is just
wasteful you're wasting users resources
to battle resources it's just bad for
environment so so how you would do it
properly well one of the things actually
was presented by get like this life that
builder will work very nice in this kind
of situations I'll present you like an
hour way how you can approach this so
your starting point from this kind of
task is a view model scope so you just
run this load function in this femoral
scope then we introduce a function in
the model that you connect our UI nav
model
third when you grab a node well as we
discussed it's a network call somewhere
inside of his load node
so it's I seen Fran separation so it
should be suspended and well now we need
somehow connect this note that is loaded
in one scope and load not functions will
be called in some other scope well I
will use complete deferrable well it
sounds a bit scary but it's actually a
very simple thing you will see in a
second so how we use it we complete our
deferred with a note that we loaded it
just put the note into this object
nothing happens and readers request the
note like with a weight function from
this deferred if a note isn't ready yet
then the reader will be suspended if it
is ready we will resumed right away so
this is how implemented our review model
and last step we just call that in our
lifecycle scope this load note function
that we introduced in a view model and
our network called properly is is
properly executed in view model scope so
it's not affected by configuration
changes and our update UI function
doesn't leak once your life cycle one
cycle owner gets destroyed however once
we add the fragment into the picture
things get complicated as always so
right we decided to run the fragment
transaction and you will get a legal
state exception because nothing
guarantees you that you are in the
correct state that allows you to execute
fragment transaction and we did
something smart and introduced some
special function that help you to deal
with these kind of situations and this
is going to be a bit tricky because it's
actually fairly complicated things but
what it does this block will run only
when your application is started or
resumed meaning that is enough for a
ground and this block will be suspended
when the application is when your life
cycle is just created so let's take a
look on an example what it actually
means so
you have this function I read it is
called probably in the beginning your
block will be suspended because note is
not ready then once is ready in usual
situation we would resume execution and
proceed to the next line
but with lunch when started function
we're going to go and check life cycle
if it is not started we going suspend
forever until the life cycle will become
started again and once it is started
when we're going to proceed to the next
line and in the execute this transaction
so we won't run into this exception
situation so one thing I want to
highlight that this block is suspended
during creation and it's a different
frame from being canceled because
cancellation is still provided where
lifecycle scope when destroy haven't
happen and now as you can see we it's
something that we definitely need to
test and Chango
how do that thanks Sergey so we talk to
you a lot about car routines today we
talked about how they can help clean up
api's by replacing callbacks with
suspend and resume we talked about
different ways they can be used in
different situations and that's all
great that's awesome but if they were
difficult to test that just be a
non-starter it wouldn't be something
that I would take very seriously as a
thing to use so what I want to talk to
you about right now is Kotlin XK routine
test it's a new library came out about a
week and a half ago that's currently
marked experimental car routines API
because it needs it needs more feedback
before it makes it all the way to the
stable it's a collaboration between
Google and JetBrains to make testing
cover teens on Android very easy so it's
not coupled to any testing libraries so
you can use J unifor you can use J unit
5 you can use your own custom test
runner that you've built and this
library is going to help you test pair
routines
so I'm gonna focus in on that live data
builder that each showed and we're gonna
talk about how to write a test for that
so I'm just gonna omit one
I'm gonna wait a second and then I'm
gonna admit to so this is a relatively
simple live data so I can focus in on
how to write the test for it so to get
started we need to mock out that main
dispatcher the wipe data builder uses
dispatchers not mean by default which is
the actual main threat on Android we can
replace it with a test co-routine
dispatcher this is a special dispatcher
designed for testing carotenes and we
can make a test correcting scope this is
a scope designed for testing care
routines so then in setup you can switch
out dispatchers that main for a testing
dispatcher this will change the global
value for dispatchers that mean
immediately so the live data builder
will use the dispatcher we give it and
then in teardown reset main to the
default value and then this last line
here on the bottom is really really
important it says test scope cleanup
test care routines if you think about
what a dispatcher and a scope are doing
their very stateful right they have to
keep track of your Co routines and
actually run them so you don't call this
it's very easy to leak state between
tests so that's a lot of boilerplate so
you can go ahead and put that together
in maybe a J unit for role this doesn't
come in the library but you can write
all of that code into a rule and I would
expect to see a library that does this
relatively shortly so whatever testing
framework you're using however you
should build an abstraction that's
appropriate for your testing framework
to do that code the rule that I'm
defining here exposes test care routine
scope interface which lets me call run
blocking tests this is a cover team
builder that's optimized for testing it
works kind of like run blocking but it
makes writing a lot of tests easier oh
and it returns unit so you can use it in
single expression style in your test
then we get the subject and then we need
to start observing the live data so it
will execute remember the live data
builder won't run until someone's
observing it I'll define a little test
helper called observe for testing this
is just my test code it's not in a
library anywhere it's just gonna start
an observer and then call the block that
I passed it and back to the test the
first value has already been emitted
because I've made everything
deterministic with this this test rule
that I'm using I'm gonna use fluent
assertions to check that the value
should equal one and then I'm going to
advance the time by one second this is
one of the big advantages of test cut
routine dispatcher you can control
virtual time so advance time by it will
cause that delay to return immediately
and I have control over it in my test so
the second image is already done when I
get to this line of code there's no need
to spin and wait for a result and this
test won't be flaky I can just say
subject that value should equal two
and if we run it we see that our test
passes the test runs instantly in tape
instead of taking an entire second so go
check out the library be sure to file
any bugs that you find it's currently
marked experimental carotenes api until
it's had enough feedback to elevate this
table and now I'm gonna hand the mic
back to you just suspend the talk thanks
yeah
okay so I want just need stuff what is
next so today we talked about how you
can already use qualities in Android
eggs and other Android libraries we
introduced a new live data builder that
lets you integrate live data with
qualities and the new life cycle scopes
for your view model so Cora this goes
for your via model and your life cycles
now we also introduced this new
functional to my started which allows
you to run qualities based on your
lifecycle state and last but not least
we have introduced a new testing library
for Cortese
okay so earlier today we announced call
him first and for Android X and jetpack
is more like Courtis first this is a
recommendation we believe qualities
provides the best functionality and ease
of use for concurrency on Android but we
acknowledge that this is work in
progress
most of these libraries we own are
either experimental or alpha one but we
want to develop this with the community
the same way we do with architecture
components and other jetpack libraries
so you can either join us or wait six
months and then that's not using them
and as part of this you will see more
and more of coupling and qualities
coming out of jetpack so all of these
are available in lifecycle to point to
offer 0 1 starting today so please take
a look at it and let us know how you
feel about them also we really really
like Curtis thank you
[Music]